he is the hall-of-fame boxing analyst
who was ringside as part of Showtime's
coverage of mayweather mcgregor he's al
Bernstein how are you I'm good I'm doing
fine
so I guess what let's go macro here do
you think Mayweather actually executed
the gameplan and he went into to
perfection or was using that as a cover
after the fight
for having a tougher time with McGregor
than anyone he expect well gregor was a
little better than he thought he said
that at the press conference he said he
was better than he thought and he
actually said his dad in that leg up is
Floyd regular senior and he and laying
out the gameplan thought they would be
able to get to that result
a little quicker than they did um
clearly and I put this in the keys to
victory at the beginning he wanted to
take him and we talked about it they
want to take him to deep water and take
McGregor where he had never been which
is past 25 minutes of actual time yeah
in in combat which is how the longest
he's been only once in in an MMA match
so clearly that was the plan
it did go according to the way he wanted
it to fun along the way a couple of
unmistakable facts Conor McGregor was
able to get a little bit more done and I
think anybody thought he was he landed
about a hundred and eleven punches which
mean it which is more than most almost
all Mayweather opponents do during that
period of time so part of that however
who's due the fact that Mayweather
fought a different kind of fight he was
a stalker which isn't even he's never
really been that so that left him open
more to getting hit so it was a little
bit of both it was a little bit of maybe
they're having a little bit of more of a
problem than he thought uh and him
getting the job done with the plan they
they put forth so how do you think
McGregor did on Saturday night pretty
well you know some of the boxing fans
you'll find they're shocking but
sometimes on Twitter people are critical
uh you know I missed a shocker isn't
but boxing fans think I was too nice to
Conor McGregor and gave him too much
credit but I thought he did a fairly
good job officer
he wasn't we done he demonstrated as a
boxer his power is not there he throws a
lot of punches he is changing up he
throws with more power to the bodies in
the head sometimes people do pronate
their punches better to the body and get
more leverage in him but I thought
generally he did fairly well given the
fact that uh some people thought he
wasn't going to land a puncher go five
rounds al Bernstein joining me here on
the Rich Eisen show did you agree with
the stoppage of the fight was
appropriate I I think at that juncture
he happen through our function over a
minute he was getting hit with big
punches he showed his grittiness and
toughness is resiliency which we knew he
had and and he's in a very tough sport
and mixed martial arts and while he has
been submitted three times he's never
been knocked out so we knew he was
resilient he showed that but I don't
think you can criticize referee bird for
the earth for that okay something else
on the referee was very patient with
McGregor early in the fight McGregor
kind of reflexively remembers doing
those hammer punches yep which can do in
in the top of Mayweather said because
Mayweather was following his head down
you can do that in them and they can't
do in boxing I thought bird was could
have even taken a point away and he did
do that well I'm wondering if the judges
did take points away because you take a
look at the cards al two of the three
judges had had Mayweather taking two of
the first three rounds
honestly the sheer numbers and I know
it's not all done on our show Stan's
numbers I mean and a couple of those
rounds Mayweather through under ten
punches and I just don't know how a
judge could have given any of the first
three rounds to to Floyd Mayweather let
alone two of those routes so that is a
puzzlement three I think you won the
first three rounds maybe one one more
rounds along the way I see Farhad are on
official score did I'm winning one more
round
clearly
fight though by the time we got into
round seven and eight the fight was
going Mayweather's way mm-hmm al
Bernstein joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show okay so Mayweather said that
he owed the fans based on what happened
with Pacquiao and and I'm just sitting
here wondering out you know shouldn't a
guy who's forty nine I know now fifteen
you know make a lot shorter work of
somebody who who's coming from an
octagon stepping into a square ring it
doesn't matter the age or the height or
the reach you should make a lot shorter
work than that out well you can make a
case for that that's not an absurd
statement um you know there was spots in
this fight there were two factors I'm
trying to I've tried to think of these
and see if I can figure it out the one
is that as I said they were at least
forty years old coming off a 23 month
layoff so that affected him it really
did number two he's fighting a style
that normally does he doesn't walk
forward but even so you kid there were
spots in that fight with Floyd
Mayweather certainly looked like less
and we have seen before which was not
shocking because he's forty years old
and he was coming in up to each layoff
but then once he got his motor running
and of course McGregor got tired he was
able to land those right hands with
impunity and even early in the fight was
landing it at great percentage but but
it's not an unreasonable statement that
you made you know I one could make the
argument that maybe it should have
happened earlier any kind of admitted he
didn't think it would go ten mm-hmm so
and the legacy question l we all
remember obviously when somebody steps
out of the ring for the last time and
Mayweather said this this is in fact his
last fight how do you think Saturday
night affected his legacy in any way
shape or form
I don't think dramatically either way I
really don't you know he ended up
knocking out Conor McGregor he had a
little bit more problems with him then
maybe then anticipated
it wasn't a brawl that he was ripped
apart in and got a lucky punch to knock
him out no he was keep after the early
issues he started to control matters so
I don't think it affects his legacy one
way or the other it doesn't elevate it
and it doesn't pull it down I'm I'm one
of those people that is of a mind that
Floyd Mayweather is the best fighter of
this era but not in the top 15 or 20 a
long time maybe maybe 15 or 20 but maybe
25 he's certainly one of the great
fighters of all time but that's the best
thing if you're in charge of McGregor's
career what would you do MMA you made a
whole bunch of money he's talking about
a third fight with Nate Diaz I think
that makes a lot of sense and I and I
hope that this
I truly hope this is kind of a one-off
for boxing and mixed martial arts
because of these two great personalities
I just don't think it's you know
fascinating for them to mix the sports
that much I respect for both martial
arts and boxing and I think they're
separate sports and I kind of hope that
doesn't become a trend I don't know you
take a look at what we're expecting to
see from pay-per-view numbers al I think
people would beg to differ that it's not
intriguing or fascinating market being
what it is if you something you said
tomorrow that I don't know maybe not
much well I guess if McGregor was still
involved in it was I guess if McGregor
was gotta find another boxer in theory
you could sell paper views on what level
I don't know but I can't think of any
other match featuring a boxer and an MMA
practitioner where you could get these
kind of numbers it's just I think it
would be difficult alright so and and a
few weeks out now the big fight that's
going on in Dallas what are your what
are your two cents on that subject I
think that's a terrific fight and it's
great because the the styles of the two
fighters that both nobody will be moving
that much they'll be right in a pocket
golovkin is a huge power puncher Canelo
is the excellent offensive fighter and
the question will be whether canal
can take the punches often and Kenny
hurt golovkin
the fight is is an appropriate one for
boxing daft it's coming in here when
boxers had a great year in 2012 and and
that fight is is going to further
enhance it but I think it's gonna be a
terrific fight and I hope I hope the
media covers that fight and I thought
our fights on another network when it's
just for the sake of boxing I hope the
media covers that sport with that fight
with a great zeal and intensity as we
covered this one and so we shouldn't we
shouldn't look forward to the winner of
that taking on let's just state what
Nate Diaz somebody like that or out we
had Larry Merchant here the other day he
was just he said it was like Chuck the
Bayonne bleeder Wepner against Andre the
Giant I think the purists are not happy
not happy
you know III understand the viewpoint
that of people that maybe this was
slightly inappropriate I totally get
that I understand it but it wasn't Andre
the Giant and and Chuck Wepner III you
know I I don't think it was that and in
fact it showed that it wasn't that
because this one man is that active
participant in combat sports at a young
age and did his best if he had more
power trust me he would have made it
even more difficult for Mayweather but
as a boxer he's not yet isn't all
pronate those punches yet and yes Tyler
McGregor had started out he was a boxing
with his younger if he had stuck with
boxing he would have been a very good
boxer I mean our friendship Jeremy shap
who as you know has got the the roots in
the in the sweet science and covering it
and talking about it he said if McGregor
fans think this is some kind of moral
victory than moral victories aren't what
they used to be he tweeted that out
after the fight yeah I'm not happy you
know everywhere the boxing fans some
I'm happy with me because I was nice
from aggregor so and I'm so I don't know
I love you I'll always take care of
thanks for calling you got an al
Bernstein on Twitter
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me
you'll enjoy